>> AND WE ARE BACK.
WE ARE BACK, IT IS TUESDAY.
AN NBA TUESDAY RIGHT HERE ON
THE BLEACHER REPORT.
WE ARE GOING TO GET RIGHT TO IT.
BEFORE WE GET TO IN, I WANT TO
INTRODUCE US.
I HAVE TO INTRODUCE EVERYBODY
THAT YOU SEE HERE.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY, NEXT TO
ME IS THE MAN THAT I CALL THEM
BE.
NEXT TO HIM, IT'S THE PRODUCER,
PRODUCER RYAN.
WE APPRECIATE YOU GUYS FOR
BEING HERE, APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
FOR TAPPING IN.
I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO DOING THIS
SHOW, WE'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR TO
DOING THIS PARLAY, LOOKING FOR
IT TO CACHING.
LAST WEEK, LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
LAST WEEK, WE HIT 4 LEGS, BUT
WE DID NOT COMPLETE THE JOB,
TODAY WE HAVE TO COMPLETE THE
JOB.
WE NEED YOUR HELP, YOUR GUYS
HELP AT HOME IN ORDER FOR US TO
COMPLETE THE JOB.
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU GUYS TO
VOTE, GIVE US THUMBS UP, THUMBS
DOWN ON PICKS.
RESPOND TO US.
BUT MAN, MICHAEL, PRODUCER RYAN,
SHOULD BE JUST GET RIGHT INTO
HIM?
>> I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE
QUICK COMMENT ABOUT KLAY
SELLING, THAT WAS THE MOST
DEPRESSING WATCH, AND I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE BAD VIBES ALL
NIGHT, BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS FIRST SPAKE IS SOLID.
KLAY WAS OUR FIRST PICK LAST
TIME, LET'S MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
GOOD ONE.
>> GO AHEAD, GREG.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO VOUCH
AND REPEAT AFTER MICHAEL,
PLEASE MAKE SURE, LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE LOCKED AND
LOADED FROM THE FIRST PICK TO
THE LAST.
WE WERE LOCKED AND LOADED FROM
PICK 2-5 LAST WEEK.
WE HAVE TO BE LOCKED AND LOADED
FOR PICK 1-5.
RYAN, WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE CHAT?
>> I'M ALREADY SEEING ANTHONY
DAVIS 10 PLUS REBOUNDS FROM LAY
LOW 11.
HE SAYS HE NEEDS FAITH RESTORED,
YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY ONE,
BROTHER.
I NEED FAITH RESTORED AS WELL.
YOU SAID IT, GREG, EARLIER, YOU
SAID YOU'RE ALL ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE DIDN'T GET THE JOB DONE, BUT
WE GOT THE JOB DONE LAST WEEK.
KLAY DIDN'T GET THE JOB DONE.
WE DID EVERYTHING ELSE.
WE NEED HIM TO SCORE, AND HE
DIDN'T DO THAT.
>> FOR REAL, I MADE ALL OF MY
SHOTS.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> I DIDN'T TAKE ANY, BUT I
DIDN'T MISS ANY.
>> LET'S JUST BE CLEAR TO THE
AUDIENCE, ARE WE STICKING TO
THE TNT GAMES?
ARE WE MAKING THIS CALL RIGHT
NOW?
SHOULD BE JUST STICK TO THE TNT
GAMES?
>> YES, I HAVE BEEF WITH WHAT
WE DID LAST WEEK, BECAUSE
FANDUEL RUNS A PROMO THAT THERE
IS A NO SWEAT UP TO 25 DOLLARS
IF THERE IS ONLY THE TNT GAMES.
WE ADDED A NON-TNT GAME LAST
WEEK, AND WHEN WE LAST, I WAS
LIKE, AT LEAST I'LL GET A FREE
25 DOLLAR BED, AND I DIDN'T GET
THAT.
WE ARE STICKING TO TNT TONIGHT.
>> THAT'S ON US, IT'S ON US.
>> IT'S NOT ALL OF US, YEAH.
LIKE I SAID, ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> WE'LL STICK TO TNT, WILL
STICK TO TNT.
I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE POPPING
OFF IN THE COMMENTS.
SHOULD WE JUST GET IT STARTED?
WE HAVE TO GET IT STARTED WITH
THE FIRST ONE.
GUYS, THIS IS NOT WHAT I AM
LOCKING IN, I'M JUST BRINGING A
SUGGESTION HERE.
WE'VE GOT MY MEN BURNT 23, HE
HAS BRON, 10 ASSISTS.
THE PRODUCER JUST WHISPERED IN
MY EAR AND SAID THE LAKERS
CAVS.
THE LAKERS AND CAVS.
>> LAKERS CAVS, AND HE SAID
BRON WITH 10 ASSISTS, WHICH WE
DON'T HAVE TO LOCK IN, WE JUST
HAVE TO GET A CONVERSATION
STARTER GOING.
THE OVER UNDER IS 5 AND A HALF,
THAT IS SO MUCH.
WHAT ARE WE DOING IN THE
COMMENTS?
>> I PERSONALLY GET IT, BECAUSE
WE NOW HAVE TOLD THE ENTIRE
AUDIENCE THAT YOU CAN GET A
FREE BET BACK, AND SO IT ALMOST
FEELS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE CRAZIEST TAKES IN HERE.
WE HAVE HAD A 6-1 PARLAY LAST
WEEK, IT WAS PRETTY CLOSE, 7-1,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I FEEL LIKE PEOPLE WANT A 12-1
PARLAY TODAY, AND I'M NOT GOING
TO BE THE PERSON TO TELL THEM
THAT THEY CAN'T HAVE IT.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK HAPPENS.
>> GREG, YOU KNOW THAT I DON'T
EVER TURN THAT OPPORTUNITY
DOWN.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> I KNOW YOU WILL SEE MY FACE,
JUST ONE WIN AWAY FROM WINNING,
AND NOW WE'RE SITTING HERE
DEBATING ON ONE.
I'M JUST TRYING TO WIN.
>> GREG NEEDS WINNERS,
APPRECIATE THAT.
>> AND LET'S TALK TO THE PEOPLE,
LET'S TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
LEBRON JAMES OVER POINTS IS
FREE, MONEY, THAT'S WITH JAKE
SAYING THAT IT IS GAMES AGAINST
HIS OVER --
OVER AND POINTS, FREE MONEY
AGAINST HIS OLDER TEAMS.
OR FORMER TEAMS.
>> I DON'T HATE IT AT ALL.
>> TONGUE TWISTERS OVER HERE.
>> 26 AND A HALF DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE TOO MUCH TO ME IN THE SPOT.
IT FEELS TO ME LIKE HE WILL
PROBABLY GET CLOSE TO THAT
NUMBER.
MY CAUTION IS THAT SINCE LAST
WEEK, AD HAS BEEN PLAYING HIS
BUTT OFF.
55 POINT GAME RECENTLY, YOU
HAVE TO THINK THAT THIS GAME
WILL NOT BE SUPER HIGH SCORING.
I THINK THE 26 AND A HALF MAYBE
TOO MANY, BUT WE CAN GET A
LITTLE LOWER THAN THAT
POTENTIALLY.
I DO LOVE THE NARRATIVE, HE
GOES HOME AND PLAYS AGAINST
CLEVELAND.
I DO LIKE THE PICK, WHOEVER
DROPPED THAT I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT ON.
>> YOU MENTIONED A.D., THEY
DROPPED HIM OVER 26 AND A HALF
POINTS, THAT'S WHAT THE STREETS
ARE SAYING.
>> WOW, I LIKE THAT.
THE STREETS ARE ALSO SAYING --
JAMES OVER 26 AND A HALF POINTS.
ALSO, DOMINIC SHELTON, LEBRON
THE PEOPLE ARE TALKING, SHOULD
WE LOCK THIS IN AND JUST GET A
VOTE SO THAT WE CAN SEE?
CAN WE GET A TEMPERATURE CHECK?
>> I LIKE IT.
>> I DO LIKE THE AD PICK, BUT
RYAN YOU HAVE TO GET THE PEOPLE
TO VOTE.
WE NEED 2-3 PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS VOUCHING FOR THE PICK.
>> I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
>> WE'LL START OFF WITH BRON.
GO AHEAD, BRIAN, TALK.
>> DO WE NEED TO START WITH A
STRAIGHT OVER UNDER?
CAN WE TEASED THIS DOWN A
LITTLE BIT?
>> LET'S TEASE IT DOWN,
BROTHER.
>> YOU'RE THE PRODUCER, DO YOUR
JOB!
[LAUGHTER] >> OH MY GOODNESS.
THE PEOPLE ARE TELLING US TO
START IT, WE HAVE TO GET
SOMETHING NOW.
>> 25, 25.
LET ME GET THIS OUT OF HERE.
>> AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THE PEOPLE.
BRO, THAT IS STUPID!
NO, WE SHOULD NOT DO THAT.
WE SHOULD NOT DO THAT.
THAT IS MINUS --
LOOK AT THE ODDS.
>> MINUS 1-90, WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM?
>> AND OVER 26 AND A HALF?
WHEN INTO HALF POINTS WAS MINUS
1-15?
>> HE'S GETTING SO FRUSTRATED.
>> WE'RE SAVING OURSELVES FROM
A BAD BEAT.
IF THERE IS A BAD BEAT, AND WE
DID NOT TAKE THIS, I'LL BE
MIND-BLOWING.
>> I MIGHT BLAME THIS IS COMING
FROM YOU OUT OF ALL PEOPLE, MR.
GO BIG OR GO HOME.
MR. 21-1 PARLAY'S ONLY, AND
YOU'RE SITTING HERE TELLING ME
THAT YOU WANT TO TAKE A MINUS
1-90 COMPARED TO A MINUS 1-15
OVER ONE AND A HALF POINTS?
>> THIS IS MY FAVORITE SHOW IN
THE WORLD.
>> IF WE TAKE OVER 26 AND A
HALF AND HE FINISHES AT 25 OR
26, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ME IN
YOUR VENMO REQUESTS, THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> LOOK AT THE CHAT SAYING, I'M
GOOD.
SOMEBODY SAYING, YOU MIGHT AS
WELL AS THE 26 AND A HALF.
>> GIVE THE PEOPLE WHAT THEY
WANT.
>> EXACTLY, WHERE WE'VE BEEN
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION, RYAN?
I'M JUST MIND-BLOWING THAT IT'S
WITH YOU.
MR. GO BIG OR GO HOME >> RYAN,
I'M WITH GREG.
>> IT RUNS WITH YOU.
>> PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT THEY
WANT ANTHONY DAVIS.
>> I SEE THAT.
>> EVANS JUMPS AND INSIDE OVER
26 AND A HALF, BUT I DON'T WANT
TO DO TO LAKERS OVER 26 AND A
HALF.
>> YEAH, THAT'S CRAZY, THERE'S
NO WAY TO DO THAT.
THAT'S JUST ASSUMING THIS IS
GOING TO BE A REALLY HIGH
SCORING AND CLOSE GAME.
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE CLEVELAND CAVALIERS TO
MAYBE BLOW THEM OUT TONIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T THINK
THAT BETTING BOTH OF THEM IS A
SMART SPOT, BUT WE'LL LET THE
CHATS ASIDE.
YOU CAN MAKE A CASE FOR BOTH OF
THEM TO SCORE THAT.
>> I LOVE THE AD PLAY, BUT IF
RYAN DOESN'T WANT TO DO THAT,
--
>> I HONESTLY LIKE THE AD PLAY
BETTER THAN LEBRON, BUT THIS IS
A PARLAY OF THE PEOPLE.
WE JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO GET IN.
LOGAN GELLER IS IN HERE SAYING
THIS IS AN ANTHONY DAVIS NIGHT.
I DON'T THINK IT ONLY HAS TO BE
POINTS.
>> WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT AT THE
END, HAVE THE PEOPLE DECIDE IF
WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH BRON OR
AD.
WE KNOW WE WANT TO GO WITH A
POINT TOTAL, WE HAVE TO FIGURE
THAT OUT.
LET'S MOVE ON, I SEE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS.
I SEE LONNIE WALKER 15, I SEE
RUSS TO COVER HIS ASSIST TOTAL.
I SEE THAT A LOT IN THE CHAT.
>> SHOULD WE JUST PUT IT DOWN
AND LET THE PEOPLE VOTE?
>> I THINK SO.
>> OVER 6 AND A HALF?
>> 6 AND A HALF.
DO YOU WANT TO GO LOOK AT SOME
ALTERNATES?
WE CAN GET SMART.
WE CAN GET SMART ABOUT IT.
[LAUGHTER] >> WE'RE PLAYING
PINGPONG WITH SMART AND SILLY
OVER HERE.
>> JUST THROW THE MINUS 1000 IN
THERE.
>> IT WILL HIT!
>> THAT'S MINUS 1-85 FOR 6
ASSISTS?
>> YES.
DON'T DO THIS AGAIN.
>> COME ON, BRO, COME ON.
>> RYAN, WHY ARE WE EVEN HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION?
>> THIS IS TWICE IN 10 MINUTES.
[LAUGHTER] >> I'M SO CONFUSED.
>> THERE'S NO WAY YOU'RE
SERIOUS.
>> RYAN, THIS IS MY
EXPLANATION.
WE KNOW NOW, AND WE HAVE BEEN
INFORMED --
>> WHY ARE YOU BUYING HALF A
POINT FOR LIKE --
>> WE ARE GOING TO GET THE
MONEY BACK IF IT DOESN'T HIT
ANYWAYS, SO WHY WOULD WE ERR ON
THE SIDE OF CAUTION WHEN IT IS
A FREE ROLL.
>> RYAN, YOU ARE MR. GO BIG!
>> LOOK AT THIS!
IT'S BEGGING US TO TAKE IN.
>> WE'RE TELLING YOU TO TAKE IT!
[LAUGHTER] >> RYAN, YOU ARE
HILARIOUS.
GO AHEAD.
>> I'M LOOKING AT THE CHAT AND
EVERYBODY AGREES WITH US, AND
THEY ARE NOT AGREEING WITH RYAN,
AND I THINK THAT IS FUNNY.
>> IT'S MESSING ME UP, I'M
USUALLY A MAN OF THE CHAT, I
LOOKED DOWN AND EVERYBODY IS
AGREEING.
>> YOU DO HAVE SOME SUPPORT.
DOMINIC SAYS SAFE CALL ON THIS,
WHEN RUSS, 6 ASSISTS.
>> AND ALSO SEE FLIP DOLLAR 23
SAYING ANTHONY DAVIS OVER 3
ASSISTS, BUT LET'S NOT FORGET,
WE HAVE ANOTHER GAME WE HAVE TO
COVER HERE.
>> WE'VE GOT ANOTHER GAME
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT SOME POWER IN
THE OTHER GAME AS WELL.
>> I'VE BEEN SEEING LUKA, A LOT
OF PEOPLE SAYING LUKA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
LUKA, WE WILL SEE.
WE NEED YOU GUYS TO FILL THESE
COMMENTS OF, WHAT DO YOU LIKE
ABOUT THE DALLAS MAVERICKS
DENVER NUGGETS GAME?
LUCAS SITTING AT 32 AND A HALF?
>> HE'S BEEN COVERING THAT
NUMBER A LOT.
IT'S IMPRESSIVE TO SEE WHAT
HE'S BEEN DOING, 40 POINT
TRIPLE DOUBLES, HE HAD --
I THINK SOME TIME LAST NAME HIT
40 12-12, AND SO I DON'T KNOW.
>> RYAN, THE PEOPLE ARE SO
FUNNY.
THEY'RE FILLING THE COMPASSION
FOR YOU, SAYING THAT HE HAS
BEEN THROUGH SOME BAD BEATS,
AND SO THAT'S WHY HE WANTS THE
5 POINTS DOWN.
>> I'VE BEEN THROUGH WAR WITH
THESE BETS.
>> THEY'RE FEELING
COMPASSIONATE.
HERE WE GO, LOOK AT, 25 POINTS.
I FEEL LIKE THAT IS GOING TO BE
A LOT OF JUICE.
773, LUKA 25 POINTS, AK-47 39
SAYS THAT LUKA 2 THREES.
>> THERE YOU GO.
THAT CAUGHT MY EYE.
>> THE LINE IS 2 AND A HALF,
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO STRAIGHT
TO 2.
THERE WE GO, WHAT DO WE THINK?
>> I LIKE IT.
WE HAVE TO GET SOME LOCK LEGS
IN HERE.
>> THAT LOOKS GOOD TO ME.
NOT SAYING MUCH ABOUT THE --
I GUESS HERE WE GO, RICKIE
SAYING JOKER TRIPLE DOUBLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN ADD THAT
TO THIS PARLAY, BUT THAT DOES
MEAN THAT HE'S GOING TO GRAB A
BUNCH OF BOARDS.
IF ANYBODY HAS TAKES ON THE
JOKER, THIS IS A PRETTY AWESOME
MATCHUP ON TNT.
>> I ALSO LIKE HIS ASSISTS MOST
OF THE TIME.
>> HERE WE GO.
I SEE SOME PEOPLE IN THE
COMMENTS, JOKIC WITH 10 BOARDS?
10 BOARDS?
>> WHAT'S HIS LINE?
10 AND A HALF.
>> WE ALREADY KNOW HOW THIS IS
GOING TO GO.
[LAUGHTER] >> GREG, HOLD ON.
THIS MAN IS GUN SHY NOW BECAUSE
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS JUST
GOING TO GET FIRED UP IN THE
CHAT.
>> YOU GUYS KNOW WHERE I STAND
ON THIS, A LET YOU GO AHEAD.
[LAUGHTER] >> RYAN, IF WE DO 9
REBOUNDS INSTEAD OF 10, WOULD
YOU FEEL BETTER ABOUT THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN DO 9.
WE CAN DO 8, AND IT WOULD NOT
DO ANYTHING IN THIS PARLOR.
AND SO WHAT DO WE HAVE?
>> I JUST WANT YOU TO GET BACK
TO NORMAL, TODAY HAS REALLY
THROWN A WRENCH IN YOUR
PRODUCER SKILLS AND YOU'RE
BEING GUN SHY.
I NEEDED TO COME WITH YOUR
STRONG, HARDENED TAKES LIKE
ALWAYS, BECAUSE WE WILL
CONTINUE, AND WE WILL MOVE ON.
>> RYAN IS PLAYING SCARED!
[LAUGHTER] >> LOOK, JADEN
JOINER SAID THAT HE HAS 16
BOARDS AGAINST THE MAVS LAST
GAME, HE THINKS HE CAN GET 10
TONIGHT.
>> I LIKE IT, THAT'S THE SCOOP
RIGHT THERE, THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT.
16 BOARDS LAST MASSIVE GAME,
THEY HAD JOKER A 10 BOARDS.
THE THING ABOUT THE MAVS THAT
IS INTERESTING, THEY'RE A FEAST
OR FAMINE TEAM, SHOOTING A LOT
OF THREES, A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOARDS, AND
CERTAINLY BEN SEEMS LIKE A
SOLID NUMBER FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
JOE KITS TO GET.
>> RYAN, I KNOW YOU'RE A WIZARD
AT CONTROLLING THE FANDUEL PAGE,
IS THERE AN OPTION, IS THERE AN
OPTION FOR ALTERNATE REBOUNDS?
SOMEBODY IS IN THE COMMENTS
SAYING THAT YOU CAN GO TO
ALTERNATE REBOUNDS TO GET THE 9,
IS THERE AN OPTION FOR THAT?
>> NOT TO GET THE 9, BUT TO GET
THE 10, AND THAT'S WHAT I'VE
PUT IN THE HERE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT LOOKS GOOD.
SO WE'VE GOT 4 LEGS, JUST TO
RECAP QUICKLY.
LUKA 2 THREES, JOKIC 10 BOARDS,
AND THEN RYAN, WHAT DO WE HAVE
FOR THE CAVS?
>> WE HAVE LEBRON OVER 26 AND A
HALF AND WESTBROOK AT OVER 6
AND A HALF ASSISTS, WHICH WE
WILL CIRCLE BACK ON IN A FEW
MINUTES HERE.
>> WE'RE DEFINITELY GOING TO
CIRCLE BACK ON THE LEBRON ONE.
I'VE GOT DYNAMIC SAYING JAMAL
MURRAY POINTS.
>> 19 AND A HALF?
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> GREG, YOU ARE THE NUMBERS
GUY, CAN YOU PULL UP HIS STATS
RECENTLY, SEE HOW MANY TIMES
HE'S GONE OVER 20?
>> MY BOY JAMAL MURRAY, LET ME
LOOK HIM UP, LET ME SEE.
>> WHILE YOU DO THAT, I'M IN
THE CHAT, AND I'M SEEING
BELIEVE IN THE REEVES 4
REBOUNDS.
>> WE DID HAVE AUSTIN REAVES IN
A PARLAY BEFORE, AND HE
DEFINITELY CAME THROUGH WITH US.
>> HE SAYS AD 4-1 MADE 3.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, WE HAD
18 POINTS, 20, 26, 30, 1-21 IN
HIS LAST 5.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A TRACK
MEET, A GAME THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY HIGH SCORING.
FOR A LOT OF REASONS, 20 POINTS
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A LIGHT.
I WONDER WHAT THE CHAT THINKS.
SYLVESTER SAYS THAT MURRAY IS
GOOD FOR A 20 PIECE NUGGET WITH
A CHECK MARK.
I LOVE THOSE VIBES, AND SO I
LIKE THE LEG HERE.
>> IT MIGHT BE A LEG.
REBOUNDS, RYAN, YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR 3 POINTERS?
>> ARE WE TALKING ABOUT 4 AD?
THEY DON'T HAVE IT FOR HIM
UNFORTUNATELY.
I WAS LOOKING AT REBOUNDS
BECAUSE SOMEBODY SAID AR.
>> AR-15, MY BAD, BROTHER.
>> HIS LINE IS 2 AND A HALF,
AND SO THAT'S GOING TO BE A NO
FOR ME TO.
>> WE MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING HERE
FOR JAMAL MURRAY, JUST GO TO IT,
RYAN, WHILE YOU GO TO IT, THE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FILL UP THE
COMMENTS AND LET US KNOW IF
THEY LIKE JAMAL MURRAY GETTING
A 20 PIECE MCNUTT GET TONIGHT
AGAINST THOSE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
WHO IS GOING TO GUARD HIM?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> IT WOULD PROBABLY FALL ON
TIM HARDAWAY JUNIOR AND DORIAN
FINNEY-SMITH.
THEY ARE GOOD DEFENDERS, NOT
BAD DEFENDERS.
I THINK JAMAL MURRAY IS STILL
GETTING HIS LEGS BACK FROM HIS
INJURY, BUT THE NUMBERS HAVE
NOT LIED.
HE HAS HAD A BUNCH OF PRETTY --
HE'S BEEN OVER 4 OF THE LAST 5
GAMES, AND I EXPECT A LOT OF
POINTS IN THIS GAME.
THAT COULD BE A GOOD PLAY.
>> THAT IS WHAT IT WOULD LOOK
LIKE IN THE PARLAY.
>> I CAN'T SEE IT.
>> IT'S 10-1.
>> ISN'T THAT WHAT YOU GUYS
WANT?
>> KIND OF, WE'RE GOING TO GET
THE MONEY BACK.
>> WAIT, I AM SO CONFUSED RIGHT
NOW.
RYAN, WHAT ARE YOU HESITANT?
USUALLY YOU WANT 22, 21-1 ODDS.
THIS IS 10-1, AND YOU'RE BEING
HESITANT.
WE NEEDED 5, CHECK WHAT IS
GOING ON?
>> I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE WE
HAVE ENOUGH SAFE IN THE BANK
LEGS.
I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE A LOT OF
ONES THAT ARE RIGHT ON THE
LINE.
WE ALSO HAVE A LOT OF OVERS.
I PREFER TO LOCK SOME STUFF
DOWN.
I WOULD BE ONE TO SUGGEST CAVS
MONEY LINE.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
UNPACK THAT IN THE 2ND.
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF GOOD TAKES
IN THE CHAT.
JAYDEN SAYS THAT WESTBROOK 6
ASSISTS, CAVS GIVE UP THE 2ND
MOST ASSISTS TO POINT GUARDS.
WESTBROOK'S LINE IS ONLY HAD 6.
WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD,
BECAUSE WE WERE GOING TO DO 6,
BUT WE DON'T HAVE TO BUY 6,
BECAUSE WE CAN HAVE A LOOK AT
THE ORIGINAL LINE.
RYAN'S ARGUMENT IS THAT IF WE
BUY IT DOWN TO 6, WE AVOID A
BAD BEAT, AND WE'RE ALREADY AT
A 10TH ONE PARLAY.
I GET WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM,
RYAN, IF WE WANT TO SCALE IT
BACK A LITTLE BIT I'M NOT
AGAINST THAT.
WE STILL HAVE TO TALK ABOUT AD
VERSUS LEBRON, BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT WE HAVE
TO SWAP OUT LEBRON AND PUT IN
AD.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT DOES TO THE
PARLAY IF WE DO 6 PLUS ASSISTS.
>> THIS IS AN NBA SHOW, BUT
YES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE PARLAY.
>> STOP, YOU'RE A WIZARD, GREG.
YOU'VE GOT TOO MUCH GOING ON.
WE MOVE IT DOWN TO 6, IS THAT
WHAT WE DID?
WE ARE STILL AT 8-1.
I DON'T HATE THAT.
>> I ALSO SAW ANOTHER ONE, WHAT
DO WE HAVE NOW, RYAN?
GO OVER IT.
>> LOOK AT WITH 2 PLUS 3 IS,
JOKIC 10 REBOUNDS, JAMAL MURRAY
OVER 19 AND A HALF POINTS,
LEBRON OVER 26 AND A HALF
POINTS, AND WESTBROOK AT 6 PLUS
ASSISTS.
>> AND WHAT ARE THE ODDS?
>> PLUS 801.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING, RYAN?
WHAT ABOUT LEBRON JAMES, HERE
WE GO.
LET'S DO THIS.
I AM GOING TO GO UNPACK
SOMETHING REALLY QUICK, I'LL BE
RIGHT BACK.
WHEN I OWE UNPACK THIS, BECAUSE
WE JUST GOT BREAKING NEWS.
WHEN I UNPACK THIS, WHEN I COME
BACK, I WANT THUMBS UP, THUMBS
UP IF YOU GUYS WANT LEBRON
JAMES TO STAY IN THE PARLAY,
THUMBS DOWN IF YOU GUYS WANT TO
REPLACE HIM WITH AD.
THUMBS UP FOR LEBRON JAMES,
THUMBS DOWN IF YOU WANT TO
REPLACE HIM WITH AD, LET US
KNOW.
YOU GUYS TALK REALLY QUICK, I'M
GOING TO GO UNPACK THIS.
I GOT SOME BREAKING NEWS.
>> THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW, BUT I
RESPECT IT.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT HE'S GOING
TO DO.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HE'S
GOING TO DO, HE'S GOT ME
LOOKING AT MY PHONE TO SEE IF
BREAKING NEWS HAPPENED HERE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON.
WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT.
>> LET'S STAY FOCUSED, WE ARE
GOING TO FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR
NOT WE NEED AD OR LEBRON IN
THIS PARLAY.
PEOPLE ARE IN THE CHAT, MY BOY
DARIAN, HE'S SAYING LEBRON 25
POINTS.
I SEE A THUMBS UP, I SEE A
THUMBS DOWN, I SEE A THUMBS UP
FROM SECURED TO, AND LANE 60.
EVERYBODY LOVES LEBRON TONIGHT,
UNFORTUNATELY, GREG.
UNLESS YOU ARE ON BOARD.
THAT WAS A QUICK UNPACKING,
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> EVERYONE'S ROCKING WITH
LEBRON?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE IT.
>> I LIKE, IT HE'S GOING BACK,
LOOK AT THE COMMENTS EARLIER.
HE'S GOING BACK TO PLAY AGAINST
HIS OLD TEAM, GOING BACK TO
CLEVELAND, HIS HOMETOWN, HE'S
GOING TO WANT TO SHOW UP.
HE'S GOING TO WANT TO SHOW UP.
>> I DON'T HATE IT.
RYAN'S ARGUMENT IS THAT WE JUST
TEASE IT DOWN TO 25, BUT I
DON'T WANT TO OPEN THIS CAN OF
WORMS.
>> DOES THE CHAT WANT TO TEASE
IT DOWN TO 25?
I WONDER IF THEY FEEL
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE DID 10
MINUTES AGO.
THAT'S MY THING.
>> DEFINITELY THEY DON'T,
LEBRON ALWAYS POPS OF IN
CLEVELAND.
A LOTS OF THUMBS UP, LOTS OF
THUMBS UP.
LISTEN, YOU GUYS ARE DRIVING
THIS PARLAY.
THE PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING, AND
THE PEOPLE LOOK LIKE THEY WANT
LEBRON IN THEIR.
>> YES.
THE CHAT IS BREAKING NEWS, IS
THIS REAL?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN IF IT'S
REAL?
I HAD TO GO UNPACK FOR A
REASON.
IT'S REAL.
>> ARE WE ALLOWED TO SAY?
>> THIS IS THE NBA SHOW.
HOW ARE WE ON THIS PARLAY?
WE HAVE TO LIKE BACK IN, WE
HAVE 5 PICKS, LET'S REVIEW,
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> HONESTLY, GO LOOK AT
15-PLUS.
THAT WAS NOT FROM ME, THAT IS
FROM A COMMENTER.
THEY SAID JAMAL MURRAY, 15
PLAYS.
>> LET'S TAKE IT OUT, GO TO 15
PLUS, 5-20.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO 5 LEGS, I
THINK WE NEED TO SIT AT LEAST
600.
>> WE'RE AT 5-20!
>> LUKA 2 THREES, JOKIC 10
BOARDS, MARIE 15 POINTS.
>> PUT RUSSELL WESTBROOK BACK
TO 6 AND A HALF AND WE'RE AT
600, OR ABOVE 600.
>> THAT FEELS LIKE THE PLAY,
ALL RIGHT, I CAN GET BEHIND
THAT.
I LIKE THAT MOORE, JAMAL MURRAY,
RUSS CAN COOK.
>> DON'T SAY RUSS AND COOK, WE
KNOW HOW THAT GOES.
[LAUGHTER] >> WE ARE ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
>> I LIKE THIS.
>> WHAT IS THAT, RYAN?
>> THAT WOULD BE PLUS 6-81.
I WANT THE CHATS THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
>> WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT IF
THEY REALLY LIKE THE FULL
PARLAY.
>> FOR ME, THE REALLY BIG THING
THAT I'M HUNG UP ON IS LEBRON.
WOULD WE FEEL SAFER WITH HIM 2
PLUS THREES?
>> HE DOES SHOOT A LOT OF THEM,
I PERSONALLY WOULDN'T MIND
THAT.
WHAT IS HIS NUMBER 4 THREES?
WHAT WOULD THAT DO?
>> IT IS AT 2 AND A HALF RIGHT
NOW.
>> SO THEN WE WOULD NEED 2 PLUS,
MINUS THE 3-30, IT'S PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO DO AS WELL.
>> WHO IS THAT FOR?
LEBRON.
>> ARE WE TRYING TO TAKE OUT
HIS POINTS AND PUT THE THREES
IN THERE?
>> YES, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WHY DON'T WE JUST DO AD?
OH, THE AUDIENCE.
>> I MEAN JARRETT ALLEN IS OUT
TONIGHT.
>> WHO'S GUARDING HIM?
>> THAT'S A GOOD SCOOP.
MY EVALUATION ON AD, IT'S THAT
HE PLAYS BETTER WHEN THE
COMPETITION IS BETTER.
>> GOOD TAKE.
>> I HAVE A WRENCH TO THROW AT
YOU GUYS.
>> JAY HERNANDEZ, TIM HARDAWAY
JUNIOR, HE'S BEEN KILLING IT ON
THE THREES.
OVER 3.5 MADE THREES.
TE'A WILLIAMS SAYS LOCK THAT.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU MENTION THE
HARDAWAY THREES --
THE HARDAWAY JUNIOR THREES?
>> PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING, MAN, I
DON'T KNOW IF WE WANT TO HAVE 4
PLAYERS FROM THAT ONE GAME, BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PEOPLE WANT
THAT.
>> HERE THIS ONE OUT.
LEBRON GOT THE ANKLE INJURY.
AS A LAKER FAN, BRON TO COVER
IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY.
AD, ALL CAPS, HE'S GOING TO
COVER!
WAYNE 60 IS SAYING THAT I LIKE
AD TONIGHT IF ALLEN IS NOT
PLAYING.
WE DID SEE SAY THAT, SO CALL ME
CRAZY, BUT WHAT IF WE TOOK
LEBRON UNDER 26 AND A HALF
POINTS?
>> THIS IS ACTUALLY CRAZY,
BECAUSE THE ENTIRE CHAT IS
SAYING OVER, AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO JUST FLIP.
NO, WE CAN DO THAT.
>> CAN WE ASK THE CHAD?
THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN.
THUMBS UP OR THUMBS DOWN IF YOU
ARE ALL IN ON LEBRON UNDER 26
AND A HALF POINTS.
>> WE HAVE TO GET A VIBE CHECK,
LET ME LOOK UP LEBRON'S NUMBERS
IN RECENT GAMES.
THE CHAT JUST MENTIONED THAT HE
HAS HAD AN ANKLE INJURY.
>> I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT MY
GESTURE IS CONFUSING.
THUMBS UP IS THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THE UNDER, THUMBS
DOWN IS SHUT UP RYAN, GET LET
GREG TALK.
>> SOMEBODY SAID ABSOLUTELY
NOT.
[LAUGHTER] >> RYAN, THAT MIGHT
BE THE WORST TAKE OF 2022.
LEBRON JAMES'S LAST 5 GAMES, 29,
28, 31, 39, AND 21.
>> ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
>> THIS IS A LOCK.
THIS IS IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, WE MIGHT
AS WELL JUST ROCK.
>> THIS IS IT?
>> CHAT, LET US KNOW.
RYAN, GO OVER THE PARLAY.
>> THIS IS A.
TELL US IF YOU LIKE IT, THUMBS
UP, THUMBS DOWN.
LUKA DONCIC WITH 2 PLUS THREES,
JOKIC 10 PLUS REBOUNDS, JAMAL
MURRAY 15 PLUS POINTS, THE
LEBRON OVER 26 AND A HALF
POINTS, RUSSELL WESTBROOK, OVER
6 AND A HALF ASSISTS.
>> RYAN, I'M SO SORRY, WHAT DID
YOU TELL THE CHAT?
THUMBS DOWN FOR WHAT?
I SEE A LOT OF THUMBS DOWN.
>> THEY MIGHT STILL BE TELLING
ME THAT MY LEBRON TAKE WAS
TRASH.
>> THE PRODUCER SAID SHUT A
BRIAN, SO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE COMMENTS ARE SAYING THAT.
>> PATRICK SAID THAT YOU ARE
CRAZY, AND SO YES.
I ASKED FOR IT, TO BE FAIR I
DID ASK FOR THAT.
>> OKAY, I'M SORRY RYAN, I
APOLOGIZE, AND I KNOW YOU
REPEATED THE PARLAY 7 DIFFERENT
TIMES, BUT I THINK WE'RE
FEELING GOOD.
WE'RE FEELING GOOD ABOUT THIS
PARLAY, CAN YOU REPEAT THE
PARLAY, WITH THE ODDS WERE ONE
MORE TIME?
>> REALLY QUICK, AK-47 SAYS
THAT RYAN NEED SOME MILK.
>> HE NEEDS SOME MILK!
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
I'M GOING TO REPEAT THIS PARLAY
ONE MORE TIME.
AK-47, PLEASE EXPLAIN WHAT THAT
MEANS.
LUKA DONCIC WITH 2 PLUS THREES,
NICOLA JOKIC, 10 PLUS REBOUNDS,
JAMAL MURRAY, 15 PLUS POINTS,
LEBRON JAMES WITH OVER 26 AND A
HALF POINTS, RUSSELL WESTBROOK
OVER 6 AND A HALF ASSISTS.
YOU ADD THAT TOGETHER, YOU GET
A 5 LEG SAME GAME PARLAY ON THE
NBA TNT GAMES, THAT ADDS UP TO
PLUS 6-81.
>> AND REMEMBER, IF YOU BET,
YOU GET YOUR MONEY BACK IF IT
DOES NOT HIT.
NO SWEAT, NO SWEAT.
25 DOLLARS TO WIN 1-70.
>> CHAD, ARE WE GOOD?
CHAT, WE ARE LOCKING THIS IN.
WE'RE NOT GOING BACK, I'M
CALLING, IT'S PUTTING MY FOOT
DOWN, PUTTING THE STAMP ON IT.
WE ARE LOCKING THIS PARLAY IN.
YOU CAN TELL ON FANDUEL, JUST
LIKE MY MAN MIKE SAID, IT'S
FREE.
YOU DON'T LOSE ANY MONEY IF THE
BET LOSES, IT'S A FREE ROLL.
>> BUT REMEMBER, GREG, IF
LEBRON SCORES 25 OR 26,
REMEMBER HE DROPPED ME YOU'RE
VANNA.
>> WHAT IF HE DOES GO OVER?
DO I WIN?
>> YOU EARN A LOSE LOSE
SITUATION, BECAUSE I WILL NOT
GIVE YOU YOUR CREDIT IF HE GOES
OVER, BUT I WILL BLAME YOU IF
HE DOESN'T.
>> I GOT YOU, I GOT YOU.
.
RYAN, LET'S HOP INTO THIS CHAT,
WE'LL SEE WHAT THE PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
ARE THERE ANY BETS TO GRADE?
ARE THEY GIVING US OTHER PARLAY
LEGS?
WE'LL JUST GRADE THEM, BECAUSE
WE ALREADY LOCKED IN OUR
PARLAY.
WE LOCKED IT IN, BUT YOU GUYS
PROBABLY HAVE OTHER LEGS, AND
WE WILL GRADE THOSE, AND YOU
GUYS CAN PROBABLY GO PUT THOSE
INTO SINGLE BETS.
>> YES SIR, LONNIE WALKER OVER.
LET'S GO CHECK TO POINTS, SEE
WHAT THAT IS, 12 AND A HALF.
OVER 12 AND A HALF POINTS.
>> I LIKE THAT PLAY, WE'VE GOT
LONNIE WALKER IN OUR FIRST
PARLAY THAT WE NEED, AND THAT
HIT, PRETTY CERTAIN.
WE LOVE THOSE VIBES.
12 AND A HALF SEEMS LIKE AN
EASY ONE FOR HIM, HE'S DOING IT
ALL, INSIDE AND ASIDE, AND SO
WE DEFINITELY LIKE THAT PLAY.
IF I DEGRADED, I WOULD GIVE IT
A B+.
>> I WOULD GIVE IT A SOLID B, I
LIKE IT.
LONNIE HAS TO SCORE IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO WIN, AND SO 12 AND
A HALF.
>> A COUPLE THREES, I LIKE IT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO THEM HUSTLE IN
THE CHAT, HOW DO WE GET THE NO
SWEAT MONEY BACK?
FIRST THING, YOU MUST BE
BETTING ON FANDUEL.
2ND, GO UP TO THE TOP BAR AND
CLICK OPT IN BEFORE YOU PUT THE
PARLAY IN.
DO NOT ADD ANY LEGS FROM GAMES
THAT ARE NOT ON TNT.
CAVS VERSUS LAKERS, MAVERICKS
VERSUS NUGGETS, IF YOU TAILED
THE PARLAY, I THINK YOU GET
YOUR MONEY BACK UP TO 25
DOLLARS.
THAT'S IT, THOSE ARE THE RULES.
>> RYAN, 2 MORE COMMENTERS AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO GET UP OUT
OF HERE.
>> REALLY QUICK, DARIAN 85 SAYS
THAT RYAN NEEDS HIM ALMOND
BILL.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
>> THIS IS WHAT IT MEANS.
THIS IS WHAT IT MEANS.
THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED, RYAN.
YOU NEED TO DRINK SOME OF THIS
AND GET RIGHT.
I LIKE HOW MY MAN SAID ALL MEN
BILL, SAID IT TO THAT GUY, HE
DRINKS QUALITY MILK.
>> HE KNOWS I CAN'T DO DAIRY.
ROBERT EPICENTERS SAYS THAT
RYAN OVER 3 AND A HALF TERRIBLE
TAKES BEFORE THIS ENDS.
[LAUGHTER] >> THIS IS THE
FUNNIEST SHOW, BECAUSE THE CHAT
HAS BEEN SO CONNECTED TO RYAN
FOR LIKE A MONTH, AND THEY
FINALLY ARE RIPPING HIM APART.
>> I'M NOT AFRAID OF YOU, CHAT,
I'LL KEEP READING YOUR COMMENTS
ALL NIGHT LONG.
WADE 60, MAX'S TRUCE OVER 3 AND
A HALF THREES TONIGHT.
>> FUN FACT ABOUT MAX STRUFF'S,
WE WENT TO THE SAME COLLEGE,
LEWIS UNIVERSITY.
BEFORE HE WENT TO DEPAUL, I'M
TAKING THE OVER, THIS IS AN A
PLUS TAKE, 11.
>> I KNOW YOU SEE THE CHAT,
RYAN, I KNOW YOU SEE ALL OF THE
LAUGHING EMOJI'S, LAUGHING AT
THE ALMOND MILK.
>> WHAT IS WITH THE MILK?
>> YOU NEED TO DRINK SOME,
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME.
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET UP OUT OF
HERE.
I'M GOING TO SEND RYAN A COUPLE
OF BATCHES OF ALMOND MILK, SO
THAT HE CAN GET RIGHT FOR THE
NEXT SHOW, NEXT TUESDAY.
LET'S REVIEW THE PARLAY ONE
MORE TIME, RYAN, I KNOW I HAD
YOU TO IT LIKE 5 DIFFERENT
TIMES.
THE PRODUCER WHISPERED IN MY
EAR AND SAID TO REVIEW THE
PARLAY.
GIVE IT TO THE PEOPLE.
>> LOOK AT THIS, WE'VE GOT IT
BUILT OUT ON THE SCREEN HERE.
LUKA DONCIC, 2 PLUS THREES,
JOKIC WITH 10 REBOUNDS, JAMAL
MURRAY, 15 PLUS POINTS.
LEBRON, OVER 26 AND A HALF
POINTS.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK, OVER 6 AND A
HALF ASSISTS.
AS YOU SEE HERE, WE HAVE HAD
THAT ALL UP IN THE 5 WAY PARLAY,
IT COMES OUT TO 6-81.
>> THAT IS THE PART THEY WERE
ROCKING WITH.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS RIDE WITH US
ON FANDUEL.
MY NAME IS GREG, THE GUY NEXT
TO ME, I CALL HIM MB, AND NEXT
TO HIM IS THE MAN THAT WE LIKE
TO CALL PRODUCER RYAN.
WE ARE OUT OF HERE, I WAS GOING
TO MAKE A MILK JOKE, BUT I'M
NOT EVEN GOING TO DO THAT TO
YOU.
[LAUGHTER] BUT THIS IS WHAT I'M
GOING TO DO, I'M GOING TO DRINK
SOMETHING.
♪ ♪ ♪